good afternoon welcome to the first in
our series of research Without Borders
this academic year I hope you are
picking up or sitting on the list of
other sessions we've got a really
exciting program scheduled for this
semester and next semester my name is
Patricia Renfro I'm the deputy
university librarian and I'm very
pleased to introduce this session on the
promise of peer-review we hear lots of
comments and questions about peer review
throughout academia does today's
networked environment often new and
better ways to ensure the quality of
published scholarship is open
peer-review desirable what's the quality
of the peer reviews themselves how
useful are reviews to the authors and I
think also interesting how do we find
out how effective the peer review system
is since it's mostly under wraps and
spread across this very wide range of
disciplines so we have three speakers
today our main speaker and I'll
introduce all three of them right now
our main speaker is Vivian Siegel Vivian
is the research professor of medicine
and cell and developmental biology at
Vanderbilt University where she directs
the center for science communication she
is currently the executive editor of the
Journal of the American Society of
Nephrology and the launch
editor-in-chief of the journal disease
models and mechanisms dr. Siegel is a
former chief editor of the journal Cell
and molecular cell and a former editor
of developmental cell she was the
founding executive director of the
Public Library of Science and one of the
launch editors of plus biology as one of
the responders we have Susan Witte susan
is associate professor at the Columbia
University School of Social Work and
she's the associate director of the
University social intervention group her
research and teaching focuses on the
development testing and dissemination of
prevention and treatment interventions
targeting the co-occurrence of hiv/aids
risk behaviors substance abuse and
interpersonal violence among vulnerable
populations her work has been presented
at national and international venues and
published in social work and public
health peer-reviewed journals and our
second responder is Gary not really he
is the gata ceman professor of
educational research and professor of
sociology and education at Teachers
College he is the director of the
Gottesman libraries at Teachers College
and director of Teachers College ed lab
the design and development unit devoted
to creating new educational
possibilities for the information age
he's the executive editor of the
Teachers College record and has served
as editor of the American educational
research journal and as chair of the
publication's Committee of the American
educational research Association so
three people who've been deeply immersed
in journal publishing and in
contributing to journals so I'd like to
us Vivian to start us off
thank you for having me and thanks
everyone for coming I'm hoping we'll
have a lively discussion and so even
though I think we've organized it with
me speaking for a while and having some
formal responses I encourage you to jump
up and interrupt and really if I can
walk away with a bunch of new ways of
thinking about peer review and what we
might do to the system I'll be very very
happy indeed so I'm here okay so I just
want to just outline what I'm gonna try
to do with this talk um you'll you'll
you'll figure out over the course of it
that I Carole I worry a lot about bias
the bias that we all bring to the
process of publishing and to the process
of peer review but to have that
conversation in this room I think we
need to know who we are in this room and
all that just you've heard about me and
I want to hear about you a bit talk a
bit about why we publish at all on both
the selfish and the community-based
reasons for doing that
and then what what does peer review
about and then maybe I want to show you
a little bit of data about the peer
review processes I've picked it out and
it is very particular to the experiences
iPad as a author and an editor and a
reviewer of basic biomedical research
and to some degree clinical research it
is not humanities it's not Social Work
but and so I'm really looking forward to
hearing how this perspective might be
similar or different in other fields and
I'll and I hope that we can discuss both
small changes you know ways we could
twiddle peer review a bit to make it a
little less biased a little more likely
to give what we're hoping peer review
will give us and then think about some
larger you know maybe more dramatic
changes and what we would need to do if
we all agreed as a community of scholars
that we actually need you know that peer
review isn't giving us what we need and
maybe even journals aren't giving us
what we need how do we create a new
system that will enable us to advance in
our careers as scholars and we rely so
much on peer reviewed journals of high
stature to do that for us today that
that would require a lot of investment
from a lot of different parties so
you've heard a bit about my background
um I am
basic researcher by training I've been
an editor and an author and a reviewer
researcher and an authors editor - at
Vanderbilt and I'm currently and I
believe that's where my other slide was
running the Center for science
communication which does a lot around
the issue of publishing learning how to
write well learning publishing strategy
and being a good editor - so I work with
faculty who want to become editors of
journals to think about best practices
okay so who I'm just curious about who
is in this room so how many among you
consider yourselves scholars of some
sort doing research in your own field so
that's a third or so of you pre-tenure
oh good set post tenure yes Susan you're
just posting it's about half and half
sciences humanities
okay so we're split up so this will be
interesting
I'm how many of you function as
reviewers at journals a subset and I'm
not some of the pre-tenure people not so
many um editors of journals - publishers
are there any ah hi welcome - yes you've
been I've been a publisher to actually
librarians of course and you care a lot
about information getting it sharing it
effectively okay so when I talk when I
ever get whenever I give a talk on
publishing writing papers strategy I
think about why do we do it to begin
with and I believe they're both selfish
and community based reasons one is to
claim that discovery interpretation
analysis you got there before your
competition anyone who's read the
double-helix kind of knows that in a
sense of competition that's inherent
there and if you did something that was
right and you got there first you
advance your career you advance it
through promotions you advance it
through getting funding to do future
research should and so on so there's
they're really selfish reasons
associated with publishing and then
there's what I consider the real reason
we publish which is to share what we've
figured out because you know i okay so I
come from a but biology base I've
Algie background the last research one
of the last research projects I worked
on involved female sterile fruit flies
and I used to say you know from their
perspective of a fly if you're sterile
you might as well be dead so from the
perspective research if you don't
communicate what you've done so that
other people can think about it build on
it using their own careers you might as
well have not done it at all and that's
you know so it's both selfish but also
community-based and I think it's
certainly true isn't biomedicine but I
would argue that it's true across all of
scholarship that we depend on the
research that other people have done and
our impact if you want to think about
that but the the impact of our own work
is to some degree measured by how people
use it and develop further from it ok
and so how do we do that these days well
we use peer-reviewed journals of the
highest possible stature and I see that
and it's you know it's heartbreaking to
me the stature element I won't talk
about it very much today but if we get
back to it I think we all know the
importance of journal stature in terms
of promotions and grants and all the
rest of it so we want some and and and
then I guess you know one way of
thinking about stature is if you can get
your journal into this really important
if you get your paper into this really
important journal then you have somebody
has decided that it's likely to be
really important and so you don't have
to wait for the importance to be proven
by the fact that other people have
actually made use of it or talk about it
or find it important you actually have
some sort of pre-filtering function
provided by journals and the reputations
and we use peer review to somehow give
you a sense that you really did have a
right to claim that discovery as yours
so you use reviewers to somehow be able
to help you help the journal assess
whether you get to make that claim the
discovery so journals use it as I said
to find out whether you have a right to
make that claim and in the basic
sciences we would say whether the
conclusions you draw from your research
but I think that's true too in the
humanities whether you justified them
through analysis or through data
gathering and whether they're new
whether there's it's changes somehow the
way people who wouldn't
who've thought about this field for a
long time to think about that problem
and then to get some gay just okay if
it's both believable and knew that it's
important and that's a kind of much
slippery slope there kind of because you
know what's important is you know what
we find interesting and what we find
interesting depends very much on who we
are and what we find interesting so
that's a kind of harder one to get henna
but I think everybody asked reviewers to
do some sort of assessment of that so I
asked of authors and I'd sort of curious
and today when you think about what
you're going to publish would you
publish in a journal that didn't have
peer-review nobody raises their hands so
we sort of we've we've committed
ourselves to the view that there's
something about peer-review that's
magical that somehow guarantees for us
the value of the thing we publish so I
tell you a small personal story the
first paper I ever published was
published in the Journal of cell biology
and I'll show you some data about
Journal of cell biology in a little bit
and it wasn't peer-reviewed and I
freaked out
it was submitted by my adviser through
to the journal cell biology the handling
editor was his PhD advisor he was well
equipped to assess the science twenty
four hours later the paper was impressed
and I thought oh my god something's
going to be wrong and it's okay it's
been fine but I do it scared me there's
something you think that they're gonna
catch mistakes and we'll talk about
whether reviewers catch mistakes in a
minute and so kind of the next question
is what do you expect to get from those
comments of the reviewers that's going
to improve your paper
I'm just so you want peer review because
you want that stamp that says this is
good but is there something like it is
there something you want beyond that
beyond somebody saying yes I believe
this is a great paper what do you want
okay that's a great thing you get from
review I completely agree with that what
I would ask you is the next question do
you need reviewers in the context of a
journal submission to do that you know
so I I have my pay everything I publish
I write mostly editorials these days
everything I publish I use peers I use
peers in my field and I use peers
outside my field to look at what I've
written to tell me whether my arguments
are persuasive whether they have whether
their own experiences change their
perspective and I do that before I ever
submit anything do you do that before
you submit anything yes right so the
question is why do you need a nun so so
I would ask you to just muddle it over
saying I told it that's peer review and
its purest form right and what I'm going
I hope I can argue is that peer review
when it's tied to journal submission
gets real it's hard for reviewers to do
that well because of all the biases that
come in um so do you ever get frustrated
by the review process in that it doesn't
give you what you expect that it asks
for things that are unreasonable that it
seems like the reviewers don't know your
field as well as you do which actually
you hope they don't because you're the
expert right does that ever do you ever
get frustrated I think that's probably
often the case and if you ever felt that
a review you've seen is biased and I
think all I mean I you know it's one of
those things that I'll get to I mean we
expect this absence of bias in the
review system that hello were human you
know and so I think bias actually exist
so reviewers those we've done that
why do you agree to review a paper in
the first place somebody tell me why do
you review service to the community so
you just feel it's your job and you'll
do it does anyone do it because they
want to get a advance view of something
that's relevant to their own research do
they do it because they feel that by
being a reviewer they have an influence
over what's considered important
so a reviewer can be incredibly
important by helping set the standards
community standards for what's
considered a compelling argument whether
it's in science or philosophy or
anything else right so they do it I
think it is important and I think that's
one of the if you look at in the u.s.
the Office of Research integrity for you
know mostly biomedicine that is
considered one of the main reviewer jobs
is to kind of recognize that you're
setting a community standard by what you
asked for I think that's that's right do
you ever worry about your own biases as
reviewers I do I mean I definitely I
think do you recuse yourself generally
from work that disagrees with work
you've had and the results you've had in
the past work things that affect what
you're working on now or do you feel
that even though you know that you have
your own biases you can somehow stand
above them you think you can you like to
think you can okay okay so my
perspective having seen lots of refuse
in journals like cell and plus biology
and the journals I work on now Jason and
DMM is that the methodological issue
which is a really important one often is
missing from a review that I see when
you get to some of these really high
certainly it's the kind of highest
profile journals they tend to think well
fit I don't see it as a cell paper I
don't even have to think about the
methodology and so there are a lot of
journals and the reviews become
dismissive and the reason for that being
dismissive we can I think we is worth
discussing and these days and it wasn't
true when I started in research there
seems to be a request for additional
work
oh I mean I've seen in the past decade I
can count on my hands the number of
times I've accepted a paper or reviewers
have recommended that a paper be
accepted without revision and I have
handled something like 10,000 papers in
that period that's a tiny you know 0.1%
of the papers I see
these days and that I should say that's
different for my own experience and
experience with my peers so I just
turned 50 and I published six first
author papers as a graduate student I
had papers accepted and I papers
rejected but I never was asked to do
another experiment actually in that time
so there's been a transition I'll show
you some data on that and so when the
reviewers asked for additional work
editors tend to just follow on that
request and I think there is an inherent
fear particularly at high stature places
in bio and basic science where the
editors are not full-time academics and
I think it's particularly true there
there's a real fear of publishing
publishing as a public act everyone
knows when you publish something that
turns out to be flawed and if the
reviewers aren't you know addressing the
technical quality of the work and you go
off to your next meeting with people
you'd been graduate students where their
postdocs like how come you didn't you
didn't see that flaw that glaring flaw
on the paper it's terrifying so a lot of
editors will just insist that every
reviewer gets satisfied to the nth
degree and so that can really slow the
process down and if the paper is
rejected after two or three rounds of
review which happens not unusually in
journals like nature and science and
cell then it starts all over again and
so some people I've seen this this chart
from a colleague of mine the University
of Iowa about a particular paper he
published that took something like three
years from start to finish before he
went from his first submission to
actually see in the light of day and now
I worked in a public library of science
where we you know I'm a big open access
advocate and one of our arguments for
access is that the faster you can get
the work out there for other people to
see and use the faster research goes now
phileas editors are creating two years
three-year delays from submission to
acceptance for for Rupe for things that
may not really matter then we are
creating a much bigger problem than the
six months to a year or whatever better
not that now exists in the current um
the current you know time from from
publication to when a lot of journals
now make their work feel available and I
think editors really need to think about
what they're doing when they're just
asking for
experiments okay so this led me to write
an editorial a couple of years ago where
I said it's ironic here we are in this
Internet era where we could blog our
results if we wanted to or put them out
on Google as a little entity of
knowledge we submit them to these
journals and it stinks it takes longer
my senses it takes longer than it ever
did to get published and I realized Here
I am a scientist by training and I just
put out this claim so I wanted to know
whether that was true at least in the
field in which I've worked so I looked
at the Journal of cell biology I said it
was the first journal that I'd ever
published it and that's why I had a
particular interest in looking at it I
published my paper in June of 1985 so
it's very self oriented bit of
preliminary research I looked at two
intermediate years and I did this
analysis in 2008 and I just looked at
the published records for time sub from
submission to acceptance and I'm going
to show you those data with a little bit
of commentary as I go along so the red
lines the median okay June 8th 1985 so
that little dot at the bottom 0 days
from that was my paper so it was a
little bit unusual even then but the
median time from its from submission to
acceptance in 1985 was 87 days I believe
97 12 years later it was about the same
and then somewhere around 2000 or so
2002 2003 we got electronic journal
submission so we actually cut a lot of
time of mailing reviews out having you
know 22 weeks later getting something
back saying I can't do this if any if
everything was the same you sort of
expect the time from submission to
acceptance to go down and in clinical
research actually where people have
tracked it it has to some degree gone
down because some clinical research you
can't actually redo this you can't redo
the clinical research right that's done
it's been rearranged long before you
start it but in basic research you can
always do another experiment and here we
are where things should be moving faster
and and now we've doubled we're now 180
days and I've spoken with editors at
Journal of cell biology and they say
this is an underestimate of the real
time it take
submission to acceptance because if you
go past the time window that's required
for resubmission quite often they'll set
the clock back to zero so we're sort of
losing though so you saw some of these
outliers four hundred five hundred days
and the early things were missing a lot
of those in our in our electronic data
records because we just no longer
consider them revisions anymore but even
so our median has now gone up to six
months at a good cell biology journal
but it's not you know the thing every
cell biologist strives to get into is
the thing that's going to make their
careers no so what's happening there
it's pretty bad so this is all very
basic research oriented I understand but
I do think there's some data here behind
that claim I've made and it and it's let
a bunch of people so I was writing at a
trot chatted with people about the pain
of publishing and there been a lot of
editorials and news articles about this
gnter blobel global of nobel prize
winner here in new york i Rockefeller
said the competition among scientists is
so outrageous these days that asking for
more experiments is mostly used as a
tool to slow down a competitor either to
gain time to publish a competing result
or in general to not let the competitor
get too far ahead so reviewers are
abusing their ability to be anonymous
to ask for more experiments to just keep
their competitors from getting ahead
that's good ripples perspective a martin
raff and Peter Walter and sandy Johnson
wrote an editorial that came out in the
science that said it's really sad now
career advancement can depend more on
where you publish them what you publish
and so authors are so keen to publish in
these top journals like science that
they will carry out lots of extra work
even when the results really strengthen
the conclusions only marginally so we've
got this and it sort of led to this view
that you know something like this
running the gauntlet would be easier
than getting a paper published in
today's journal environment so it leads
us to and and I can one thing you have
self disclosure here's a bit of advice I
give when I teach publishing strategy if
your viewers are always gonna ask for
more you can anticipate that you can
guide what they request by how you write
your paper so that you leave you know
the paper is complete on the surface but
Lee
you know future direction something you
actually want to give them at the end of
the day now that is really cynical
disheartening advice that says gain the
system you know the game you know what
they're gonna do until we can change
reviewer behavior anticipate this and
I've talked to a lot of people that
publish in you know in my field the top
journals in basic biology and they all
do that and that's sad
that's really sad okay so why is that I
think it's worth kind of asking that
question and I think all the players
involved in publishing have something to
do with that I'm glad to hear you use
reviewers before you submit a paper I
think there are a lot of people in the
world that are afraid to do that that
somehow it feels less scary to send a
paper not very good shape to a journal
where everything's anonymous and the
criticism on us then to use someone down
the hall because it's really it it's
scary to you to get someone you know to
be critical it's scary to them to be
critical but I think that kind of peer
review has decreased dramatically and I
think that's a problem um some for some
reason reviewing has changed it may be
competition there's I don't think
there's been any research to gather data
on this but they're they're people of
the view that has funding drops people
in the world become more competitive in
basic biomedical research and so they
they start asking for more and more it
may be that those are the reviews
they're seeing and one of the things I
find really interesting about you know
at least you know kind of academic
scholarship within basic sciences it's
very much an apprenticeship where you
learn how to do what you're doing by
assuming that your mentors know they how
to do what they're doing
and so you write your papers the way
your mentors write their papers you
write reviews based on how you see
reviews and you're not really trained in
any in any formal way in terms of you
know kind of what is a good what does a
good paper look like what does a good
review look like what's an editor and I
think the same is true of editors
actually so I don't so there's that
problem
with the apprenticeship and so I think
part of it is that we just think that's
what we're expected to do and I think
there's a part of about the editorial
job and I'll talk about that in more
detail I think reviewer we asked
reviewers often as editors to tell us
what we should publish and I don't think
reviewers can tell editors that to do
that they really need to somehow
understand everything about that journal
and what it's publishing to understand
other decisions that are being made by
the journal and be consistent and to not
have their own inherent biases to come
out so I used at once at one time in my
career I was running three different
journals as an editor cell molecular
cell and developmental cell and I could
tell even though I didn't want it to
happen that what was flowing through one
journal over the other would influence
what editors were feeling about
particular papers if they said well
we've got tons of these kinds of papers
in this journal but we don't have enough
in that journal and then it's not really
fair to the paper to do that and you
have to know your biases to fight your
biases I think and I you know and there
I was a professional editor it was all I
was doing and I could feel that my
biases popping up so I think you know
kind of kind of asking that of reviewers
is really asking that asking too much
okay so let's think about how we might
change things if we believe it's a
problem and I'm not I've had a lot of
advice the first time I gave this talk
and I've erased most of it but to here
I'll just drumming up I think you do
need to use your peers before you submit
and reviewers and editors I think we
need to do our jobs and not each other's
jobs we need to recognize that biases
exist
to disclose biases and to err on the
side of refusal if we to avoid those
biases if we can um and when I think
about a paper I want to kind of talk a
little bit about it you know have what's
the perfect paper from the perspective
of publishing within basic research
when I teach manuscript writing I tend
to think about papers research papers
being two separate papers that are tied
together and trans one translate to the
other there's the paper you write for
other people who are doing research in
your own field and when I read papers
and fields in which I've been trained I
tend to focus on these things the
methods
you know can they possibly get data that
are meaningful based on what they're
doing the data themselves and the
legends to that so do I actually agree
to some degree you know what are the
conclusions based on looking at the data
forget for a moment what they say their
conclusions are and I would generally
not read any other part of a paper when
it's in the field as an editor or
somebody outlook thinking about a field
that's not my own I actually read
completely differently I tend to ignore
the data because I can't really
understand it and as an editor I
shouldn't be assessing it and I rely on
the paper itself to teach me about
what's going on and so they're there
they're written with different languages
and they're written with different
expectations and different audiences and
so when I teach my script writing that's
why I said those two pieces they
definitely need to tie together and they
need to translate well so they have to
be actually telling the same story but
they actually need to do trend this
outside our community changes depending
on the journals so at least in by a
basic biomedical research
the higher the stature the bigger that
outsider group and so the paper needs to
be written differently depending on what
your what your intended audience is
enough paper in your own very specific
field the editor and the reviewer have a
very similar knowledge set so one might
argue in very simple in very small
fields that the editors can function as
experts on the papers that they get okay
so the perfect paper to me is one that
can satisfy the experts right reviewers
and and experts we're going to read it
that the data do lead to those
conclusions and the conclusions will
advance their own work or thinking and
it satisfies non experts to understand
and appreciate the new acknowledge why
it's important and that translation is
accurate one of the reasons I stopped
reading this all sections of papers and
my own field as they used to anger me
they say a conclusion I'd look at the
data I go it's not rain somehow that
translation whether it's simplification
or wishful thinking or something I don't
think people check the translation very
often in the process
okay so editors expect from reviewers so
I would say for those things I think um
it's the reviewer job from the
perspective the editor is do you say it
doesn't satisfy you from the data and
can you
me whether it's been translated
appropriately and the editor can then
say if it's translated appropriately is
this something I understand why it's
important why belongs in a journal so
editor's expect reviewers to spot
methodological flaws in their area of
expertise now in basic biomedicine our
you know papers are getting really
complicated and collaborative and I
don't think any individual author could
be an expert in the entire paper nor is
any individual reviewer an expert in the
entire paper and so they expect refused
to identify flaws in their areas and by
the way to kind of disclose that they
can't assess areas that are outside
their expertise not to try to assess
areas outside their expertise um editors
expect reviewers to raise flags of some
sort you know the weather they think
there's something that's been handled
and appropriately whether something
looks like but it looks like the date
has been manipulated the data are too
good to be true there might be some
fraud going on they expect that
flag-raising they want to know about
flaws in translation because they can't
identify themselves and they want some
unbiased assessment of importance which
as you could probably tell I think is
really hard to get okay so let's just
talk about that first one so we rely on
reviewers to set standards for the field
and to assess metha find methodological
major methodological flaws okay so this
is a paper that's published by richard
smith and co so richard smith was the
editor of the british medical journal
for a long time on the effects of
training on the quality of peer-review
and so I would say BMJ is one of the few
it's not the only journal that's one of
the few journals that have started to
look at reviewer quality create
measurements that they are that they can
validate sort of assessment of reviewer
quality and then think about training
quality so what they did here is they
took standard a very kind of standard
clinical trial paper and clinical trials
are formulaic you have to have a
justification we're doing a clinical
trial in the first place you have to
work with biostatisticians to figure out
what your n is how many patients you
need to do you want to randomize it
control it if to figure out your numbers
and do some the right statistical
analysis so it's pretty straightforward
going from paper to
versus clinical trials reviewers should
all be able to repeat one of the trials
in spot methodological flaws so they
inserted 14 flaws specifically into
these papers and they asked reviewers to
identify these flaws and so here them if
they had 9 major errors did it have
justification randomization sample size
the reporting of the sample size kind of
big big problems that should block this
paper from ever going in and they
inserted 9 of those and 5 more minor
errors like no ethics committee approval
stuff like that you know and they asked
how many so they did an assessment
before training and after trace whether
you know what our what's our baseline
how many flaws do these reviewers pick
up and after I trained them to the sorts
of things we want them to look for that
all clinical trials would have how much
does that change if I actually give them
the training and how long does that
training last and so any guesses as to
how many errors are picked up by the
reviewers and Rebecca we already talked
about this you cannot 9 major errors how
many do you think for 3
no it's 2.6 was the average plus or
minus 1 or so there were nine of them so
it's like they can't these okay then
they did training if you don't apply the
data okay
then they did training and they managed
after training to get one more so if we
can't so and these are very standard
kinds of trials now I don't and we could
have a long discussion about why it is
that reviewers who agreed to be in the
study so you would imagine there's this
bias the Hawthorne effect right you sort
of know you're in a study you're gonna
do your best job you don't find these
flaws is it that you have an expectation
of the journal not sending papers with
flaws like this because editors everyone
should be able to catch them I don't
know why we can have that discussion but
that does these reviewers four things
that really should be catching aren't
catching them even after training so
they do a little bit better in six
months later that's all gone by the way
they're back to their two point six okay
so the study has confirmed the
limitations of peer review as Witten
witnessed by reviewers failure to deck
major Matt
logical errors in three straightforward
accounts of randomized controlled trials
so training led to some improvement in
the detection of errors and
recommendation but with the exception of
the recommendation these improvements
were really slight and didn't last so I
sort of wonder I'm sort of left there
going if we expect from kind of first
and foremost reviewers to be catching
methodological problems and they're
failing to do that I you know it really
makes me worried okay this is only
clinical trials and it may not be true
in your field but it's really it's
something that needs to be thought about
and I would really love to see and we're
starting to think about ways to do these
this kind of peer review research this
was a lovely one because it was really a
randomized controlled interventional
trial which is rare but to do something
like that in other areas and figure out
whether reviewers can do that yes
yes yes yes yes
that's right I think you're you're
completely right and I actually also
mean that there's another issue to them
you talked about often the reviewers are
pis
and in basic science they many pis are
not currently actively engaged in
research right so they're not going to
know okay here's you know I was a
biochemist by training you know I know
certain proteins are really sticky right
so you try a certain column everything
you know it sticks to this come alive
you know it'll stick to any column I
know that I knew that for certain
proteins in my area the Marquis I didn't
know that right so so kind of looking
for those sorts of you know how is this
what is the problem you actually would
do better for that assessment with
people are really actively engaged in
research so you know you can imagine a
review working in what you say okay I'm
going to do this you know I have more of
a perspective on the field as a whole
but I don't actually do the methods
anymore
and what I really wanted people were
actively engaged the methods to evaluate
the method it's as part of that process
that's one way you might imagine and
then they don't have been it then they
can think of it you know then the ego
isn't such an issue think say I've used
this as a training tool for my students
because they're learning how to give a
review and they're making sure that the
methods are you know they're the ones
who are up-to-date methods
right so I haven't um so a lot of the
research on peer review that I've read
is clinical you have a lot of their
editors who have gotten involved
probably well it's his story you know
like everything else it has its history
so there was a deputy editor name of
Gerald the drum and Renny
it's one of the medical journal editors
he actually started a peer review
Congress he's a medical journal editor
he said we're gonna start looking at
peer review carefully and because it was
started in medicine in a medical journal
a lot of the work has happened in
medical journals I think another reason
why a lot of that happens in medicine is
that medical journal editors whether
they're doing it with ten even if
they're doing it with ninety five
percent of their time as like the
journal editor of the New England
Journal or The Lancet or BMJ all of
those journal editors maintain their
licenses to practice so they recognized
so they actually they to recognize their
community commitment and I think that's
I think that's part of what the self
reflection reflects from my perspective
basic research editors at the highest
profile journals kind of leave their
careers and it's one of the reasons I'm
back in academia actually is because I
actually think that's dangerous to the
editorial discipline if there is one I
do think my own experience with basic
research has been that reviewers have by
and large not I mean at the highest
profile journals have not focused on
major flaws what they have picked up for
me as an editor have been things that I
thought of as new that they sort of said
you know justifiably or unjustified they
were not was not so new kind of pointing
out the data that existed that I
couldn't find back in the pre PubMed
days you know but these days with
searches that's they do that less and
less I would say I think reviewers and
basic sciences will throw out things
that slow down review without
justification quite a lot they'll do
things like this is puerile this is a
purely descriptive study there's no
mechanism here a mechanism is such a
soft term you know eased I worked for
Journal that wanted basic biological
mechanism I'm about mechanism under
basic biological processes cell but
mechanism you can always ask for more
mechanism from the basic science side
until you get to atomic resolution at
which point your some people are bored
right so all that means is you've
interested me you just I stopped with
mechanism it already not so there's kind
of so I if they say no mechanism that
stops that we already knew this I mean
every now and that you see you hear that
at a high profile journal editor will
say well it's not new I don't want it
without any evidence so one of the
things the Office of Research integrity
says is if you say something like that
give the evidence underlying that claim
show me the ten Pape the one paper the
ten papers and you know I won't give
numbers but I've certainly had the
experience that people have made that
claim and then when I've gone to do the
literature search I haven't found this
prior knowledge that's been claimed by
the reviewers and so there are those
sorts of things happen a lot in basic
science and I think that I mean on the
clinical side so the journal I work on
that's nephrology does both basic
research and clinical so I do see some
comparisons there the issue is clinical
impact right so how do I know this this
approach we better than the approach
that already exists and there are
different perspectives I think people
have different inherent views about
whether they can guess that impact right
there's you know there's a kind of
hubris element you know that happens in
all reviewing you know I don't see why
this is going to change my practice you
know it's great if you can promote it
you can immediately see it that's a good
thing it's hard in other ways Marc
Kirschner mentor of mine once challenged
me to think in retrospect at papers that
had mixed reviews so somebody who got
really excited about the paper and
somebody who was really bored by it and
so the editor tendency given that people
are afraid to publish is too rich is to
go with the most jaded review or the
person who says it's boring tends to be
right this his view as you could hear it
was that you're part that's probably the
opposite that if you out of two or three
people you can get somebody really
jazzed it's probably more likely to be
important than you know you know but
then if we can you talk about randomness
you know
you had you know three people if you you
know one of those you happen to get
excited you know so there are biases and
systemic biases that everyone has you
know positive and clinical trials
positive results over negative results
things that are dangerous you know
likely to be toxic
you know those newsworthy things your
biases in the other direction against
things that break Dogma it's harder to
the standard for proof becomes much
higher
correct and that's all that's the kind
of bias point right so that's some
that's exactly where we're headed it was
kind of the issue of bias so we just I
just mentioned the unconscious biases of
kind of positive results be more
exciting therefore more likely to be
published and that becomes really
problematic with in all research
clinical trials in particular where you
only get the positive effects and you
don't see the negative once so that's a
problem but it's true in basic research
too and all signs of research and then
there's the challenge dog line which you
just mentioned so there also reviewer
inherent biases so work that comes to
conclusions that are different than this
body of work you've built up over your
entire lifetime tell me you're not going
to I look purple it's the first paper I
was asked to handle when I was a
graduate student basically said the work
of my PhD advisor and I was this first
student was an artifact and he handed me
the paper he said show you identify the
flaw in this paper it had to be flawed
you know it disagrees with me QED it's
fly and and I went I found flaws you
know but it was definitely you know that
was my task and that's you know that's a
problem work that causes their work to
be less novel so you're working on
something you're getting ready to
publish it now if this thing comes out
it's not going to matter as much and
you're not gonna get the stature and
profile and then and their own
experience at a particular journal I
think this is really you know there was
a time and I started it so we can tell
this right there was a field
intermediate filaments was the field and
I tell you the reviewers in that field
they had the view that if they'd had a
paper reject if I saw the last decade
there was nothing in intermediate
filaments that was going to get into
cell because there was nothing that
could be more important than that paper
that had been rejected 10 years ago you
know QED it's not publishable and that
hurts the field it hurts the process of
reviewing and that one at least was
explicit it was kind of easy to see
those biases but if we go around saying
you know I'm gonna send this off to
experts and I'm going to expect them to
give me unbiased reviews you're really
in trouble you sort of need to know
their biases I had a paper that's
handled by an clinical epidemiologist at
the neurology Journal said as she looked
at her reviews this room this work
agrees with the work
for fewer one who loves the paper it
disagrees with roofie or two who hates
the paper like okay that was useful you
know and you certainly need to know that
but I remember it so kind of
systematically doing that I want to send
this to people who disagree with this
work because if they can be persuaded
that's pretty powerful but the fact that
they can't be is almost meaningless and
I you know because of the biases that
exist and so I think yes
yes I do and I think one of the things
that editors needs to need to do is sort
of recognize if they're going to use
peer-review if their reviewers are
biased but they're specialized in
particular areas and to read the reviews
remembering why they sent that paper to
that reviewer to begin with right and so
really it played the role of interpreter
and not just say well there are negative
comments here and I think one of the
things reviewers tend to do is feel they
have to comment on everything and they
will act as experts for things they
really don't know that much about and
their two editors need to say okay I'm
going to discount this negative comment
because without understanding how this
person what that wasn't my accent this
paper so you really have to somehow have
a rubric to assess the reason I think
editors by and large don't do that
anymore in many many fields we used to
it you know when I started as an editor
we started you know we felt we couldn't
review a paper until we taken really
good notes on it I think what do I need
to learn from the editors in order to
decide whether to publish the paper and
under what conditions and then when I
got through ease back I fit that into
that perspective quite often what
happens now when people as editors feel
overstretched is they'll say oh it's an
interesting topic I'll review it and see
what they say and then they try to then
they try to work out what they think and
that that's actually really hard to do
it's like trying to think with people
talking with two different voices in
each ear and you know it's just it's
really really hard um so I think you do
need to know the reviewers and other
biases and the publication history and
recognize you're also biased right so in
the fields in which I've worked I
certain know what a big deal question is
my job is and editors to know what big
deal questions are in other fields it's
really easy to yawn yeah I had a deputy
editor it's a you know if it was
molecular biology she just you know she
made it very physically obvious she
wasn't interested and that affects the
whole room you know kind of what those
things do in terms of editorial
decisions you know and you hate it hate
em tough communicate that to an author
well somebody on during editorial
meeting and so I can't publish your
paper you know it's not justifiable but
you are biased and there are things that
capture it
and things that don't and you're biased
by bad writing when it's about the data
right you're biased by lots of things by
your by what that person's history was
you know
are you trying you know here's a
reviewer who wrote something dismissive
that reviewer publishes really great
stuff in your journal are you gonna go
against that opinion even though you
think it's biased if you think that it
might mean you don't get the next paper
from this really important person you
know there are lots of hard you know
there are lots of things that come in
there that you might not want to act on
but can can sit there subconsciously
affecting your opinion okay so we just
talked about that reviewers can do
certain things but they shouldn't be the
ones to make the decisions that's the
editors job and I won't go into all of
that I published it and I think you need
editors really do need to consciously
and explicitly relieve reviewers of that
expectation so when I write letters to
reviewers now I say I'm not asking you
to tell me whether they published this
paper I want to remind you that you know
you can help me make that decision but
you're German you don't I don't expect
you to know what we're going to publish
or know what else we're doing
be wary of all kinds of bias and to
maintain a group of people you trust
that are really committed to the journal
whether it's your own internal editorial
team or handful of people who function
as academic editors for the journal they
can't be on every editorial board if be
committed to you and a handful of places
so they can really think about what is
this journal trying to achieve and how
does this paper match what we're up to
what we're trying to do you need to give
clear advice you need to provide clear
and constructive decisions to authors
and you need to recognize that actually
your duty is to publish and that you
don't want a whole eggman I found that
it took me a decade I have to admit to
where I didn't just ask for an
experiment because I knew would make the
paper better it would be better for SEL
if we had a better paper but it's not
necessarily would shift it from
publishable not published with a
publisher which is the threshold that I
should be thinking about it would be you
know you know and that's and I think
that's something a lot of editors don't
think about because it's scary to
publish
ethically you need to listen to appeals
you know it is true that editors
although they can be very clear about
what their journals about are almost by
definition not going to be expert in the
papers that they're assessing and making
decisions on and they may be following a
line of logic you'd be willing to you
know kind of be clear about what your
the logic is that led you to that
decision that may rely too heavily on
something that the field nose isn't
reproducible or you know and therefore
shouldn't be held in quite the same way
so I think that's FX and so yeah we were
talking about Sarah Palin last night you
know
bias comes in all forms and and
everybody involved in publishing is
biased all humans are biased and I think
most suggestions that I think about when
I think about improving peer-review in
the current system are really aimed at
trying to reduce bias so if you think
about the bias of a reputation of an
author own history or institution that's
what double blind peer would be is about
right it's kind of getting away from the
zip code effect as we like to say if you
think about competitions between authors
and reviewers that's what open peer
reviews about in some way you can't just
you know can't hide behind anonymity to
keep competitors work from print if you
have to sign that work and then there's
this other piece which I think you know
from my own experience is Journal
specific is reviewer history at a
particular journal which I already
talked about and so it's hard I think
not to assess a paper that you read to a
paper you've tried to publish in that
same journal and so one thing I've been
toying with is whether you can actually
create a system that does what I call
journal blind peer review a group of
journals that are in the same field all
quality journals slightly different
standards of significance or what
they're after or whatever you don't know
which journal it's at and maybe that
will help you stay away from this your
own experience at the journal and the
reason I think about this and why I
expect that it would help is my
experience launching new journals and so
of course this is just anecdotally days
of every journal I've ever launched
um when I've sent papers for review
reviewers would come back and say I
don't know what to advise you because I
don't know what you're publishing I
guess I'll just have to stick to the
strengths and weaknesses of this paper
and let you decide thank you that's all
I want you know and at the same time
others would come to me whether the
papers accepted or rejected say those
were the most constructive of these I've
ever seen and so I have this suspicion
but as a scientist by training I want
some data that if we could keep this out
of the view of the reviewer and they do
a better job and then there's the
question of whether we need peer review
at all and I do want to finish up
because I know we have we want to have
time for responses and discussion is I
do think peer review is valuable for
constructive feedback when it becomes
part of the gatekeeper function deciding
what to publish it creates it pushes
bias I think it pushes competition and
so there are people are playing with
peer review in this way sort of saying
authors get to select their reviewers or
some journals that do that
they're say I'll be happy if these
people review my paper they could have
done that before submission but kind of
can do it in the context of submission I
completely believe we need our peers to
give us feedback I'm just not so sure
that it that doing it in the context of
the journal solves more problems than it
creates my own view um do we need
journals you know you know here I've
spent my career making journals editing
journals journals function has a kind of
pre-filter source so what is it that I
actually shot to be reading and can I
advocate them in some way so that's
useful to my supposed readership these
days people climb things a lot through
searching most people I know have a
handful of journals they like to read
sometimes for the news that's in them
sometimes because it's really the
journal for their specific community and
they just want to it keeps them up to
date on those other things but a lot of
people are going after what they want
through their own searches and you know
I am struck by Richard Smith who's you
know probably done more research on peer
review that than anyone the former
editor being
no longer believes a peer review at all
he wants the crowd to assess things
after publication there are ways to
assess things after publication now I
mean we've got there all sorts of arenas
we could have it in the sciences and in
academic research as well and there are
aggregates all over the place and for
research for news and all that stuff so
we could yeah you one could imagine a
day where we lived without these pre
filters now to do that we need a
completely different tenure and
promotion and grant system we need to
accept that we don't know how important
something is going to be until it gets
used and that we can't make instant
judgments on what somebody's published
in terms of their tenure and I think
that's you know that's a big question
but I do think this quote this
discussion is really worth having
because if we you know if we are there's
so much grumbling what's going on about
peer review and yet we just kind of
accept it as the matter of course and I
think the experiments being done are
interesting but they are kind of minor
many of them are really minor expert
experiments and if it's really not
giving us what we need and it's up to us
to figure out how to do that and so I'm
just kind of reminding you of what I
think of this the perfect paper I think
you can get that paper without peer
review as part of journal submission and
I think this conversation will somehow
make it possible for us to have peer
review do what it needs to do be part of
that conversation of research and not
simply a judge over it so thank you for
your attention here and I'm going to
great thank you that was that was
fabulous so I've been asked to come and
speak for a few minutes as a respondent
to dr. Siegel's presentation as actually
as a newly tenured faculty members as
someone who has perhaps a particular
take on the peer-review system and as a
social worker actually frankly and
social science looks a little bit
different than biological or medical
sciences in terms of the review process
and its relative success so clearly the
system worked for me and my anxiety went
up two or three years ago when I
realized that I had to start making
decisions about whether to go open
access for quicker publishing or draw
that timeline of how I was going to get
me more papers into the review system
and published before my ad hoc committee
came up so that my CV was was beefed up
so certainly the system worked for me
but I think that the issue of timing and
the length of time continues to be
something that that we're all going to
struggle with unless we're going to
consider some new models that might
speed up the process I do think that in
in applied professions like a social
work that may be or social services
public health what feels different for
me is that the immediacy is not there in
peer review and so even though the time
takes you know on average at least six
months and something like the American
Journal of Public Health to 18 months to
two years from submission to publication
for some of our other journals that the
experiments the random clinical trials
the randomized clinical trials that we
tend to do take four or five years to
implement anyway so we don't have that
kind of experience where you simply sort
of unless you're doing epidemiology and
secondary data analysis you can't
actually do another experiment upon
resubmission and you have to work with
the data that you have and you have to
wait for the data to come and things
don't there's not that sort of same
competition I don't think because things
aren't moving
fast but that said I think we are
concerned about
I certainly have always been concerned
as you know up-and-coming person
recognized in my field with the kind of
contribution that I make and I think
that the convey the content of a
particular paper is often and has often
been influenced by what we were talking
about in terms of the editors take of
what the journal want how the journal
wants to represent itself but then also
who the reviewers are and what's what
works in terms of the peer-review system
I think for someone who's a junior
faculty member is to be invited to be a
reviewer at the same time that you're
submitting papers to be reviewed because
I think that that particular from sort
of a social work social justice
perspective gives you some balance right
you're making decisions and you are
seeing what's being submitted and that
gives you a little bit more
self-efficacy in terms of what your
piece of work is looking like but I
couldn't agree more I made notes I think
that if we encouraged our doctoral
students and our junior faculty to do a
much better job of peer review true peer
review prior to submission that we'd see
better quality work being moved more
quickly so I actually wonder if I've
heard peers say that they're gonna
submit something because they're gonna
get feedback from the reviewers anyway
and it's not quite ready but we'll get
that in first submission so I know that
people have been using the process in in
the way it's not directed to be used and
that can become problematic so it works
for being a reviewer and it works for
for us to be able to build our Seabee
one of the I actually thought after
reading some of the work that's been
published including your editorial or
your op-ed piece was that if I think of
that Churchill quote about democracy
like it's the best form of government
except to all others and so when when
faced with the question how would you
change peer review and make it better I
mean I kind of like it it works kind of
and then you start to make the list of
all the flaws particularly the bias and
then you take a breather heavy sigh and
I think particularly coming from
place of our academic discipline which
tries to look at the ways that we really
privilege some groups and some types of
access to knowledge versus those that
are sort of marginalized that really it
stopped to make me think what are the
better ways that we could improve peer
review to make it more democratized like
open access and of course there are
challenges with that as well
I think around the issue of flaws again
if it shapes and controls the way that
new research is screened for quality
that can be a problem and how it gets
communicated and to whom and that the
peer review process creates that border
for us between the experts and then the
general public and in in Social Work and
social sciences I think that perhaps
that's a different concern than in some
Medical Sciences in the sense that my
community of scholars you know we're
talking about randomized clinical trials
around HIV prevention interventions or
intimate partner violence prevention or
treatment programs and really those that
are making access to the the academic
journals and the empirical knowledge are
not the same people who are practicing
that in the field so this is not just a
problem a peer review this is actually
why NIH is entirely restructuring their
peer review system and their relative
value as they look at what it is that
they're going to fund moving forward
from 2010 is that we're really not doing
perhaps enough innovative and impactful
work we're keeping the academic machine
going and we are building knowledge and
again this is different because I think
in medicine it's harder to sort of see
that spinning wheels doing lots of
efficacy trials and you know we can say
for the hundredth time we found one more
program to help reduce to help increase
condom use and reduce risk well it's
it's really time to move that to evident
a to effectiveness and dissemination
research and our journals have been
developed in the last two or three
decades around best evidence but what
happens is then all the reviewers that
are part of the system
of support for best knowledge are kind
of stuck in that place of the randomized
trial is the gold standard and these are
the methods that we should be looking
for in our of you so there's not as much
room for innovation a changing way of
looking at how we might solve some of
the problems so that so that actually
speaks to I think the system of peer
review in the sense that it sort of it
separates out the expert from maybe the
lay or the practitioners who are
clinical practitioners in the field and
as well it speaks to how we can
introduce ways to shift the thinking
from time to time maybe that has to do
with a competition maybe that has to do
with NIH I think since a lot of what we
write comes from funding that has to you
has to start with the funding so maybe
as that process shifts then indeed the
peer review system work will shift
somewhat so and I guess the other thing
that I'm very concerned about in terms
of the peer review system again as how
we shift it and I don't think it's
specific to preview but how we shift it
to reach more of the practitioners how
we actually take what it is that we're
publishing in our peer reviewed journals
and are we including in the peers who
are part of the review boards
practitioners who are in the field who
actually could speak more to how we
translate from science to from bench to
trench right from from the science to
the practical application and I hope
that as we take a look at changing
peer-review moving forward that we might
be able to consider ways to strengthen
the application of the science in in
professional fields so as I was
preparing my my talk and I was stuck on
the issue of timing and how long it took
and I was thinking about this one
particular case where it took me two
years to get something published up on
my computer screen
I heard the windows be
and I got a new email and the subject
line it was from web-fed central and the
subject line was successfully publishing
your research within 48 hours and I
thought wow you know that's like under
the category of you can't make that
stuff up yes I was sitting there and I
thought I have to find out what this is
and so sure enough it was one of these I
looked more closely and it was they they
they claim that if it's a reasonably
well done study they can publish it in
48 hours but they also do post
publication review I think I love this
idea I think that that that's actually a
way to both keep a peer-review process
and then and we'll talk about this in
discussion I'm sure but that might be a
really nice compromise between keeping
intact what we know can vet best quality
science but also open up an opportunity
for the community to give reflections on
what can work and what doesn't work
about it so I love that and then there
was the August 23rd article in that
times that talked about how they did an
experiment the Shakespeare quarterly
trial where they took a corps of experts
and they posted online a series of
essays and so this would be actually
humanities I'd be really interested to
hear from humanities people in the
audience about what you think but then
they over I think a week's time 41
people made 350 comments and they used
that commentary and peer review to give
feedback to the authors to improve the
publication so I mean there's obviously
gotta be a line between how much
information goes into making a final
decision and who those peers are and
there's all kinds of quality assurance
to be built in there that that could be
quite challenging but I love that idea
and so then the last thing I want to
share is that on this issue of sort of
social justice and bias and whose biases
are determining what gets published and
how I shared this brief anecdote with a
few of you earlier that my my most
difficult rejection and thankfully I've
only had a few but the most difficult
rejection was when I submitted a piece
with a colleague we had done a
randomized
trial where we recruited 217 couples
predominantly african-american and
Latino in the South Bronx and we ran an
HIV prevention intervention where we
were testing whether we could reduce
condom we increased condom use and
reduce unprotected sex among couples
after testing a sixth session
intervention and so one of the
challenges that remains in randomized
clinical trials historically in the u.s.
continues to be the ability to recruit
minority participants you know as since
Tuskegee since the establishment of the
office of health human subjects
protections we've we still have that as
a major issue that influences the
quality of the data and the ability to
actually do research that's I think you
know gonna reach the broadest audiences
so what we decided to do we thought
would be innovative would be to do a
piece where we looked at the process of
recruitment and sort of described that
how were we successful in recruiting 217
couples how did we break down those
barriers so it was a very process
oriented paper and we combined that with
quantitative paper that looked at who
was eligible and what their
characteristics were and then who
enrolled and what their characteristics
were and there was some very interesting
statistics that sort of defined who we
missed and then we talked about it so we
put it together as two papers and the
editor of a very well-known at the time
there weren't as many AIDS education and
prevention journals but the editor
looked at both pieces and read our cover
letter that said we really think that
this is important because we really
believe that a lot of scientists are
interested in hearing more about you
know how you can first of all
successfully recruit and retain then
look at this data and so he looked at it
and he said well there's really not
enough meat in this recruitment piece
but I really like that you know data
based piece so I'm gonna keep that one
and log it in you really should try
submitting the other one to a women's
health journal or to a minority health
journal and and I kept the letter
because I was so incensed I mean I
haven't met him yet at it at a
conference but the day that I do I'm
going to tell him you know there was so
much nuanced in that communication that
made me crazy so and I know that's not
exactly a peer review
related question but but it kind of is
in the sense that he had a very strong
bias one about quantitative versus
qualitative and in terms of what he
wanted to see in his journal but we
really believed you know being on the
ground that this was an important piece
that would come that would be
complimentary and so we wound up
publishing them separately and they both
got published but it really made me
start to think more about these issues
that we're going to struggle with they
think around bias and and who controls
some of these decisions about what
publish so I think I just agreed with
just about everything Vivian said so
I'll try to add a little bit to the
discussion around around general
agreement a couple things that I think
are worth just stating at the outset and
it and it's a little counterintuitive
publishing and editing and submitting
and and so forth
at least from afar seems like a
non-emotional activity and the one thing
that that I've learned with lots of
years of editing and lots of years of
submitting and many rejections and some
acceptances is it's deeply emotional for
just about everybody involved and that
that's true of the editor it's true the
person submitting it's true of the
reviewer who invests their own personal
time and energy in the process and
expects to be respected which is
sometimes difficult for the for the
editor to do if things work out in a
particular way the other thing I'd sort
of just want to say a little bit about
is one of the interesting themes that
ran through I think the presentation was
this whole issue of bias and I think
you're absolutely right it is everywhere
in the process and what makes it
problematic is we assume that it's not
so we imagine a process that is bias
free and yet we're we're encountering it
at every step and we're encountering it
at all of the junctures so not just in
the obvious place
but in in difficult places so for
example it's very clear to me from lots
of editing that an editor can
predetermine the outcome of any
submission just by the reviewers that
they select and sometimes you know I
think editors are not as though as aware
of that fact because of course once you
get the reviews back that you expect you
reinforced in your initial notions of
the paper and you believe that in fact
we've got this objective and lovely
process but just selecting the the
reviewers I think is is is an example of
a kind of instant inter inter sees where
lots goes on that is often unseen and
unrecognized so one of the things I've
started doing in trying to talk to
people about this is really not using
the word bias because right there it
sort of loads that the discussion and so
I've shifted to talking about
perspective which everyone feels
comfortable having and everyone can
acknowledge that others have ones that
are different from their own and
sometimes people are a little more
forthcoming if they talk about their
perspective that tends to be more
appreciative of qualitative work or
quantitative work or applied work or
basic work and you can at least get
people to to feel somewhat more
comfortable the other thing that it's
useful for thinking about perspective is
journals themselves have perspectives
and in fact they're you know we
sometimes call them reputations but the
perspectives that they bring are
oftentimes what they believe to be
valuable because if if we are to keep
journals that is if we are not to give
up on journals one of the things one of
the reasons we might want to keep them
is that even before you invest the time
to read an article as a reader of a
journal that you know you believe you
know something before you make that
effort about what you're about to
experience and and that's a perspective
that that comes to the journal let me
say just a little bit about the
different actors in a try to organize it
a little bit because there was advice
for I think for all of us and in this
process so for authors I think the
advice for authors too
who share their work early share it
before they submit it is I think really
good advice
I think the complication than that
advice is that authors find themselves
in very different kinds of contexts and
some authors find themselves in very
rich contexts with very experienced
colleagues who are very gracious and
generous with their time others find
themselves and totally the opposite
either with very expert and ungracious
and ungenerous colleagues or isolated in
institutions where they're the expert on
the campus and so there are some real
issues in terms of giving back to the
issue of the idea of which which
publications are elite and which
scholars get to be elite and and who
gets to have status within the field
that those things are not all well
distributed so at some point we have to
have a enough of a forgiveness in the
system that we take in papers from
authors who are in situations where they
can't get that kind of feedback that
turns out to be a time-consuming and
difficult thing for for journals to do
over a period of time but it's something
we have to work on and it's a good
argument for having a broader set of
journals each of which might be taking a
smaller flow of papers and therefore
being able to devote more editorial time
that's not the way things tend to go but
that might be an argument for that
implications for reviewers I think it's
intriguing this notion that we would
train reviewers I think as someone in
the audience already mentioned I think
that's a hard thing to sell people on
one of the things that we've done with a
fair degree of success is not train
reviewers but we now rate and select
reviewers in a much more systematic way
than we did a decade ago so we use a
very large pool of reviewers which I've
discovered from other editors tends to
be not an uncontroversial decision that
is some editors think you should have a
very close-knit set of reviewers that
you have known since graduate school and
you can trust because you know how
they've been trained other editors take
a different perspective we've gone too
a much broader set of reviewers just
because we're looking for quality
reviews which means people who will take
the time who will deal with the
methodological issues and then we track
those reviews for their quality so we
know in our database if you've delivered
good reviews for us in the past
unfortunately your reward is we get we
ask you again so no good deed goes
unpunished in our system but it actually
I think has has some promise editors I
think the whole issue of editors is an
intriguing one and I've now been an
editor I guess for almost well not quite
20 years but a lot of editing time and I
was trying to think back and preparing
for this you know what it was like to be
in a young editor a beginning editor and
what it's like now to be an old editor
and I think one of the things I've come
to appreciate is just how little we do
to prepare people to become editors how
little support we offer them and really
how tricky that role is it's amazingly
complicated it's very easy to get in
trouble particularly in a lot of
journals there are solo editors and not
really strong editorial support systems
so so developing those kinds of systems
I think would be helpful I've been on a
board where we've recruited and
appointed and removed editors so one of
the things that's clear is the sort of
inclination and natural talent for
editing is not widely distributed among
the academic profession nor is there any
reason to believe that it should be and
so we probably under invest I think in
in how we bring people into the
editorial process and what that's like
and and that goes from everything from
the inability put to put your own work
in perspective and aside and to and to
graciously work on someone else's work
on their terms and in their perspective
but it goes beyond that another actor
that I sort of got mentioned indirectly
I would say are our review processes
tenure and promotion
career development processes and here I
think there are lots of issues that bear
on this whole process you know it
appears and I'm about to go back on to
the tenure and Promotion Committee so I
say appears but it appears to me that
those committees are increasingly
relying upon the place of publication in
making the judgments that that they are
making and they're less reliant upon
actually there I say reading the papers
and and making their own independent
judgment of that and so I think you know
what I take away from that is when we
when we sort of ask the question should
we have journals another way to ask the
question is should journals become less
important and in particular can we
imagine them being less important in the
tenure and promotion process and that
would require different ways of
conducting those kinds of reviews and
and a fair amount of work in preparing
people to engage in that process which
itself is is is complicated so I think
I'll leave it there I hope I've raised a
few questions in the in to add to the
conversation and just look forward to
folks have to say thank you all three
I'm gonna ask you all to come up to the
table here where we've got three mics
and remind everyone that we are taping
this and we do put these sessions up on
YouTube pretty quickly after the events
and all our previous talks are on
YouTube so if you ask a question be
grateful if you come to the mic in the
center of the room and if you feel like
introducing yourself we'd love you to do
that as well well I have a question just
to lead off you you did talk a little
bit about some of the alternative
publication approaches and we see that
in physics and
economics and a few other disciplines
we're seeing this long tradition of
print preprints going into the networked
environment and and having made that
transition very securely can you imagine
for example in some of your disciplines
seeing that sort of really major
transition to pre-publication preprint
publication and then the sort of
endorsement that follows heavy citation
use and so on and there was an
experiment done by nature you know where
they tried they let people opt into a
most of open review system where that at
the time is it's not quite the preprint
thing but saying okay you first submit
everyone can see it and comment on it
very very few people were willing to do
this there is a sense within basic
research that we've moved further and
further away from openly communicating
what we're doing both in terms of you
know posting preprints or even speaking
at scientific conferences there's
getting more and more of a this feel
that I'll only speak about it once it's
impressed and it's really a shame from
my perspective but there's so much fear
in a world in which the experiments
themselves are pretty easy to do there's
equipment there's stuff you can just buy
once you know what the result is it's
pretty easy to reproduce it within a lot
of modern molecular biology at least
that it's much different than physics
any kind of you need to make the
equipment to do the experiment and the
idea that somebody can go off and just
repeat it quickly is it's you know it's
dramatically different so I wish yes I
wish I could say yes but I'm not not
with the competition as we have it today
not in base in biology there's a lot of
apprehension on the part of authors as
to whether journals will then treat
those those submissions in the same way
that they would something that hadn't
been a hadn't appeared anywhere and we
get lots of questions from authors about
whether something can appear as a
technical report whether it can appear
that in their institutional repository
does that preclude publication what does
that mean and it's not that we have a
policy which precludes it but the
apprehension is already out there and
people are self censoring science
journals but I also think it would have
the experiment would have to be
conducted with post-tenure more senior
and veteran researchers who didn't
necessarily feel that their future
essentially and perhaps many do but that
their future relies on the success of
this relative experiment but I think for
pre tenured faculty who are trying to
build a CV it would be too much of a
risk so maybe small experiments and
there's a completely dramatically
diametrically opposed view which is i
only I'm I want to work on projects
where I can collaborate I'm sick of this
I have to keep it secret until it's
impressed
I believe research is better done in an
open environment and there are some
people who have moved in that direction
have chosen their projects for those
kinds of collaborations and have done so
you know quite successfully so I
wouldn't say so I think there are
pockets of exceptions there and that if
you're committed to having open
collaboration you can succeed in biology
and biochemistry and chemistry - I don't
think you it's a it's the NIC I don't
think it's the nature of the beast I
used to say when I was a student that
you had two options one was to be open
with everyone and then there was some
community standard that would say hey
you know this person's been working on
this for 10 years you know what happened
what was this person right so you're
open with everyone or you become very
private and I think that that
polarization I think is happening even
in the
I know any other questions comments
microphone we want you an on record this
time so going back to when you had the
statistics about the time it takes for
something to become published it's kind
of countered into it if that when things
move electronically it actually doubled
the time it takes to get from submission
to acceptance do you know why puzzle is
why I mean those are data and certainly
my point was that you'd think of
anything if everything were the same it
would be faster and it's not faster so
something has changed whether it's that
papers have gotten more complicated so
you need lots of different experts and
that is certainly true that we've moved
in biology from having two reviewers to
in some of these complicated papers
having three or four or five reviewers
on a single paper you get off them all
in you know you it all takes you know
it's a harder thing to orchestrate I
think reviewing has changed that's what
I think you know my own sense of it I
feel like I have to wait for a long time
for certain reviewers to get back to me
with my paper so there's not a deadline
for reviewers there is often a deadline
for reviewers but so it depends on the
field so in ecology or social science it
might be three to six months in in
journals that are that have different
fields aren't it and sell it was we
expected in two weeks you know there are
some that I say you know you know three
to six weeks I mean sort of people ask
those things that were fewers the
problem is reviewers say yes I can do
this what do you do when they don't
deliver so one of the proposals has been
send the paper out to more reviewers
than you need expecting that some subset
just won't deliver and work with the
ones you get now that might work but
given that we have multidisciplinary at
least in the fields I work and you have
these kind of multidisciplinary papers
you can't get the you know replace the
person who really understands this
aspect of the paper what
some random other person you have to
have this kind of Chinese menu that says
okay within everything I want I need
multiple people just anticipating that
people won't come through now if you're
scoring does help right so it's one of
the things that we keep track of all of
us do the work as editors do they
actually deliver when they say they will
and then you have the next problem for
basic research where you can do
experimental revision quite often you
want to send the paper back to those
reviewers and they may have had time to
do it quickly the first time around but
you can't just shift the reviewers a
second time they may be writing their
own grant or doing something else but
now the time becomes enormous because
they don't have an opportunity to opt
out this time we really need them to
look at the revision site there are a
couple of reasons for that so it sounds
like there's no advantage to be a
reviewer I mean is there some sort of
incentive for reviewers I mean I just
certainly across your career lifecycle
but particularly as junior faculty to
begin to be introduced to the new pieces
that are coming in and see what people
are writing about and so is there an
advantage it's the community service and
it's it's being part of the group that's
actually shaping what it is that's
that's being selected and how it's being
shaped but but know there's no incentive
I mean there's no real there's no
financial there's there's a bit of a
benefit to put it on your CV that you're
either an ad hoc or a regular reviewer
for a particular journal is greatest
when the paper is well matched to your
you know area of expertise because then
it's something something that will
impact your work or could impact your
work and that's just hard to do I think
getting to your other point about the
the time period I think that the major
thing that electronic submission and has
done is simply taken away the post
office as the excuse for
the delay but it's done two other things
at least as far as I can tell number one
in many cases it's made the submission
process easier which which means that
the volume of submissions increases and
not necessarily in in response to that
our journals able to actually increase
their editorial staff and then I
remember the first time I got a request
to review something electronically well
that first one I was really fast and
getting back to but when I figured out
that my email box could quickly get
filled with requests from editors
electronically asking me to review then
it slowed right down again so I think
people are getting asked to do more
reviews I think people are submitting to
more places and of course if we simply
speed it up the process right that would
make it even even worse because the same
paper would then be cycled through
multiple times until it hits so there I
don't think there is a great you know a
great answer to that question I mean I
think we've all tried to expand where we
can expand review or bowles but it's
really tough to get exactly the kind of
people that you want about uncoupling
the assessment of a paper in terms of
its methodology from and its potential
importance from whether it belongs in a
particular journal is that it can enable
those reviews to be used at multiple
journals and so you just said kind of
inherently well obviously if it goes
through multiple journals that's gonna
you're going to use reviewers more and
more times if we could undo that somehow
by having the review be fungible then I
think we could speed up the process even
if you used journals and so the
neuroscience is experimenting with that
they're a bunch of journals that have
agreed to do it not that many people are
opting in for whatever reason but it is
something that I've puzzled with and I
know that when I was at Cell Press we
used to allow people to submit to
multiple journals at the same time and
our own anecdotal experience with that
has been that reviewers
tend not to if you ask them about advice
for the journal they tend not to give
that advice equally when they're doing
multiple journals at once so they might
say there's no way this is a cell paper
sure you can publish it in Iran
but if you'd sent it directly from
neuron that her own editor would argue
they wouldn't have said the same thing
and so this is so that's that's why I
think you really need to pull the advice
piece completely out for what the
reviewers are doing and then maybe you
could you can enable movement thank you
so I'm from neurology and epidemiology
and I wanted to thank you for the
thought-provoking presentations and I
had a few questions we may be able to
start with one which is what you think
of the notion of charging authors to
publish their papers and that obviously
raises a lot of issues for the authors
and having conceived of the idea of
starting my own journal and having that
as a model definitely I sort of brush up
against different opinions so I'm
wondering what your thoughts are
believer in charging pre-publication
charges now where that money comes from
is an issue we've talked about a lot
authors at least in basic science are
charged already quite a bit to publish
their papers even if they're
subscription-based journals they're
charged for Corrections they're charged
for color they're charged for number of
pages I mean kind of historically
authors have had author side charges and
society journals historically have used
both author side charges and subside
charges to fund publication now the
problem comes with authors side charges
or to the two questions that get raised
about that or will that influence
reviewing our decision-making about what
to publish so if you're charging from
the author side won't you just be pushed
to publish everything that's like asking
Columbia if you're charging tuition
won't you just accept everyone into
Columbia because you'll get more tuition
that way you know sort of I think it's
an inherently flawed worry but people do
have it I'm one of the things we did it
plus to get around that list that people
wouldn't know who could pay and who
couldn't pay when there
looking at papers and I think that's an
important thing to create an information
barrier about charges from that side
because I do think publishers will get
invested in what they publish then the
other side is when you have options to
go to a journal that doesn't charge
versus a journal that does charge the
issue comes there are three things that
will come can you there's the issue of
can you afford it and are there wavers
if you can't there's there if you choose
to publish will that keep you from doing
something else that's research oriented
I think are two of the issues that
offers need to face which are can be
troubling those all very long answer I
think you need to create ways to create
for waivers for people who can't pay we
did that up at PLoS and you know when we
when we audited it it seemed the people
who were saying they couldn't pay really
couldn't pay you know it's some sense we
didn't ask for financials but for the
most part people didn't manipulate the
system too much I think that pocket has
to be separable from research funds I
think that's really it's really hard to
ask people to make the decision between
publishing this paper or doing the next
piece of work and I think there been
lots of work around how to do that so
that's my kind of view but I don't think
there's anything inherently bad about
other side charges but I do think there
are issues conflict interest issues that
need to be sort of tackled head-on but I
think it's probably worth noting that
wherever the funds come from to put the
journal together is probably going to
influence the nature of the
communication and one of the concerns I
have you know is it's a mild concern but
a concern is that as we move away from
having journals supported by readers
it's very likely that the nature of the
communication will become different and
if it's only a journal for authors to
satisfy authors and if it's supported by
authors that may whether that's good or
bad is a
is an open question but I think it's
going to be different than if it's
actually supported by by end consumers
and by readers and I think one of the
problems that all of the disciplines
have is a real under investment in
communicating with outside publics and
demonstrating the value of the work so I
would be concerned on that ground
I agree with that
in principle I my problem with that with
respect to kind of the role that what
the reader side charge really is I mean
so most of our reader readers side
charges are hits the librarian who's
paying that bill right it's not the
reader of the journal article and so and
and so what I have felt certainly my own
perspective about the reader the current
what we had is reader side charges is in
fact neither the author nor the reader
was paying it was a library that was
paying and so it created a really kind
of in elasticity that and no correlation
anyone who's done the study kind of
there isn't a correlation between price
and value if you perceive value as the
quality of the work the number of people
read it it you know in the you know five
or ten years ago and we you know in any
case when I last looked this up there
seemed to be an inverse correlation the
journals that had the least the smallest
readerships were the much more niche
like journals that you know they were
they had really huge charges because
only handful of librarians were paying
for them and therefore they had to cover
the whole cost whereas journals like
nature or you know or science which has
a hundred and eighty thousand
subscribers or something like that they
could bring those costs way down for any
individual user and so the one of the
things I've always liked about the the
author side charge they said at least
you see something about costs connected
to quality that you actually see the
cost even if you don't pay the cost
whereas the librarian that's my counter
side but I do agree with this public the
whole issue of a larger readership than
the ones we tend to think about within
which the authors and the readers
the same people over time the second
question that I have relates to impact
factor which I mean some of the sort of
trends that are going on right now make
me think that something that I thought
was sort of bogus to begin with is even
more bogus and I'll give you some
examples you know I think a lot of
journals are just trying to publish
reviews because that's a way to get
their impact factor out and at least in
the clinical journals those reviews
aren't very good they're not a
particularly high quality and they're
not reporting on you know new results
they're not particularly synthesizing
anything in a particularly useful way so
so I'm really wary of that and then the
other is that you know I've had journals
say we'll take that you know as an
author we'll take your paper but please
cite the following papers in this
journal you know just to boost their own
impact factor and then you know I get
these emails you know almost one you
know one a week now from journals that I
subscribe to or you know their I review
for whatever to say you know our impact
factor is up from two point one to three
point and it seems like every journals
impact factor is going up because of
these tendencies so I'm just wondering
what your thoughts are so I have a
friend Richard sever who is at Cold
Spring Harbor press now and he was hired
by the Journal of cell science many
years ago when he went to raise the
impact factor of Journal of cell science
I'm telling his story he he didn't
handle the research at all what he did
was he invited big-name people to write
reviews for the front of the journal and
the impact factor doubled at Journal of
cell science from I think it was 3 to 6
let's say I'm just making the numbers up
what really puzzled Richard and me was
that the editorial board saw this new
impact factor and said yeah I've noticed
that the paper the research papers are
getting better in the Journal of cell
science there's some interesting
phenomenon when people see an impact
factor they look at the papers in a
different way
and that really troubles me that was
coming my impact but we are definitely
moved but I want to raise a couple
things you said they are bogus numbers
so anyone noticed that act of
crystallographic a-- has a higher impact
factor than the New England Journal of
Medicine this year the reason is they
published a review it was a review of a
bit of software protein folding software
and within the review said you know if
you're if you're using the software this
would be a really good citation to use
because it's published and it tells you
about the software and you don't have
manuals aren't in PubMed so it becomes a
sizable reference it got cited 6,000
times so it's so there was one paper
there's a cancer reviews Journal that
every year every two years publishes
cancer statistics epidemiology
statistics for the u.s. those were those
reviews get cited by everyone who's
working on those cancers for the next
two years so they always have an impact
factor higher than England Journal so
yes there are ways to game the system I
think any time use and tell people to
work to a number they will figure out a
way to work to that number and that's I
think that's problem with any metric
actually but impact factor is
particularly troubling because it's not
it's not the metric you think it is
right so what's it's in the numerator is
not what you think sits there
do you have one more question yeah I
think we have time for one more question
so from from the answer you gave him
about the author is paying the journals
and also the library paying the journals
for subscriptions so journals are
getting double to pay is that right
you'd say with anything is that you have
a mixed revenue model right so you look
any almost many healthy economies will
say we want to pick up we want to mix
our revenues so that we aren't sensitive
we're not going to be sensitive to any
one thing dropping the difference
between an author pays model and a
library pays model it's the difference
between having all your money so library
will pay a subscription at the beginning
of the year and you have that all that
money for the year author pays side is
almost like a retail business right
every time you read publisher paper you
you put out a charge it's actually much
harder to get these small payments
through than it is to get these big
large payments so it's a different it's
kind of a whole different business
dynamic that happens there and the
author side but it's not it it's not a
double pay it's sort of a way of
distributing the charge now there have
been you do speak to a kind of there are
a set of journals and and one of the
journals I worked on wasn't until this
until this coming years it's been among
them a number of journals that have
moved towards hybrid models where they
said we're basically a subscription
journal but you can opt in to having
your journal be freely of your article
being freely available from the day of
publication and for that you pay a
supplementary the author side fee and
there people have worried about the
double charge the library still pays the
full subscription and now for the these
papers you you're paying extra on top of
that to have this six month window or
whatever it is where things are free
when they wouldn't otherwise be there
are librarians in the audience who can
speak to this better than I do but I do
know there have been some attempts on
the parts of some publishers to be
transparent about what they're charging
and how that those charges change as
more and more people will take up this
kind of open access option but that
they're the double the double-dipping
has been
concern as they call it well please join
me in thanking our three speakers it's
been really interesting